[Applause]
it's a good thing
[Music]
I am not so like we can compare
oh yeah
by the way touching your leg you are
shaved okay that's good to know I
I haven't got a little there's a little
bit of but it's fine no no no it's it's
pure as the driven snow okay great it's
perfect this is a
different ball game do you know what's
shave often like no it took me three
months to finally get to shave yes and I
was so it's like I feel like I
like I had a full-blown movie makeover
just by that me too I I because I have
been like deep in it work wise it's the
let and all clothes have been covering
all that part of my body it's the last
thing I think about and it has been so
liberating